[Music]
the earth
intercepts a lot of solar power a
hundred and seventy three thousand
terawatts
that's ten 000 times more power than the
planet's population uses
so is it possible that one day the world
could be completely reliant on solar
energy
to answer that question we first need to
examine how
solar panels convert solar energy to
electrical energy
solar panels are made up of smaller
units called solar cells
the most common solar cells are made
from silicon
a semiconductor that is the second most
abundant element on earth
in a solar cell crystalline silicon is
sandwiched between conductive layers
each silicon atom is connected to its
neighbors by
four strong bonds which keep the
electrons in place
so no current can flow here's the key
a silicon solar cell uses two different
layers of silicon
an n-type silicon has extra electrons
and p-type silicon has extra spaces for
electrons
called holes where the two types of
silicon meet
electrons can wander across the p n
junction
leaving a positive charge on one side
and creating negative charge
on the other you can think of light as
the flow of tiny particles
called photons shooting out from the sun
when one of these photons strikes the
silicon
cell with enough energy it can knock an
electron from its bond
leaving a hole the negatively charged
electron and location of the positively
charged hole
are now free to move around but because
of the electric field at the pn junction
they'll only go one way the electron is
drawn to the n
side while the hole is drawn to the p
side
the mobile electrons are collected by
thin
metal fingers at the top of the cell
from there
they flow through an external circuit
doing electrical work like powering a
light bulb
before returning through the conductive
aluminum sheet
on the back each silicon cell only puts
out half a vault
but you can string them together in
modules to get more power
12 photovoltaic cells are enough to
charge a cell
phone while it takes many modules to
power an entire house
electrons are the only moving parts in a
solar cell
and they all go back where they came
from there's nothing to get worn out or
used up
so solar cells can last for decades
so what's stopping us from being
completely reliant on solar power
[Music]
there are political factors at play not
to mention businesses that
lobby to maintain the status quo but for
now let's focus
on the physical and logistical
challenges and the most obvious of those
is that solar energy is unevenly
distributed
across the planet some areas are sunnier
than others
it's also inconsistent less solar energy
is available
on cloudy days or at night so a total
reliance
would require efficient ways to get
electricity from sunny spots to cloudy
ones
and effective storage of energy the
efficiency of the cell itself
is a challenge too if sunlight is
reflected instead of
absorbed or if dislodged electrons fall
back into a hole before going through
the circuit
that photons energy is lost the most
efficient
solar cell yet still only converts
46 of the available sunlight to
electricity
and most commercial systems are
currently 15 to 20 percent
efficient in spite of these limitations
it actually would be possible to power
the entire world with today's solar
technology
we'd need the funding to build the
infrastructure and a good deal of space
estimates range from tens to hundreds of
thousands of square miles
which seems like a lot but the sahara
desert alone
is over 3 million square miles in area
meanwhile solar cells are getting better
cheaper
and are competing with electricity from
the grid and innovations like floating
solar farms
may change the landscape entirely
thought experiments aside
there's the fact that over a billion
people don't have access
to a reliable electric grid especially
in developing countries
many of which are sunny so in places
like that
solar energy is already much cheaper and
safer
than available alternatives like
kerosene for say
finland or seattle though effective
solar energy may still be a little way
off
[Music]
you